a city under siege and a hospital
struggling to care for thousands despite
it tarik sister was diagnosed with gall
stones in February she has been
regularly suffering bouts of pain my
sister is supposed to have surgery they
told us to come today when we came here
today the doctor told us that the
operation theatres are closed only
emergency surgeries will be conducted
that has been asked to return in two
weeks to check for a date he's waiting
to request if she could be slotted and
earlier but that looks impossible there
are crowds of patients here waiting in
the hospital corridors to schedule
elective surgeries doctors here have
told us off-camera that they cannot
schedule these surgeries because certain
theaters are on standby for any
emergencies that might crop up because
of the tense situation on the ground
with many medical staff on reserve for
emergencies doctors say that only half
the usual amount of elective surgeries
are taking place
[Applause]
malignant cancers take precedence
doctors say anyone else will have to
keep coming back every fortnight to see
if the situation has normalized enough
for regular operations to resume a
communication blackout imposed by Indian
authorities has meant that people cannot
reach ambulances or tell their family
about the health of hospitalized loved
ones and some people are angry my sister
is very sick we can't even call an
ambulance because the phones aren't
working I had to bring her on a scooter
for over 15 kilometres let me do that
there are no communication channels
mobile services are down everything is
cut off my brother had an accident and
some kind people came to our home 25
kilometers away to tell us that's how we
found out Hassan was riding his
motorbike to his hometown in south
Kashmir a heavily restricted area to buy
medicines for his uncle he had an
accident passers-by found him barely
conscious and brought him to the
hospital
the ID card in his pocket helped them
identify where his family is has been
totally buried
how could have my family known if our
son is dead or alive no nation in the
world no civilized nation in the world
no civilized people of the world will
allow these type of restrictions of
Hasan has been put under observation for
internal bleeding he says his pain is
not only physical it is the pain of
Kashmiri s here inexplicably and
suddenly cut off from the rest of the
world waiting for normalcy that report
from DWS nimisha jaiswal she is now back
in Delhi and joins us for more on this
story hi name is Joe good to see you we
just saw their new report the
communications blackout has had serious
consequences on everyday life in Kashmir
is there any sign that these
restrictions will be lifted soon well
sue me just yesterday while we were on
our way out of the Kashmir Valley we
heard from local administration that
phone lines will be restored by
yesterday evening is what was being
reported
of course verifying this would take more
time mobile connections as well mobile
networks will be restored in a couple of
weeks according to the Home Minister of
course there is no commitment on this
front but I'm sure the belief is that
there's going to be a long wait for the
internet services to be restored because
there is a belief that internet services
actually allow for violence to break out
we attended an army briefing while we
were there an army and security forces
briefing and the officials they said
that this these last 30 days have been
the most peaceful in the valley and this
is because of the communication shut
down reports to the contrary have of
course emerged and people have to
continue living under these restrictions
until decisions are made otherwise
Nimisha this is a territory on lockdown
tell us what else you experience while
in Kashmir but for me apart from the
communications blackout there are also
curbs on our own movement now of course
a heavily militarized area like Kashmir
has always seen the presence of security
forces on the ground
but a thousands more were mobilized to
the region a month ago when the special
status was taken away from the region
and the curbs are imposed a pretty much
arbitrarily when you're actually trying
to get around security forces can decide
to start down an area which actually
leads to more rumors circulating because
there's no news there's no way to verify
what exactly is happening you can't look
something up on the internet you can't
even make a call to find out what
exactly is happening in a certain area
so these restrictions and of course
there are curves on press freedom as
well because all press all the press in
the valley have to go to one media
facilitation center there are four or
five systems there one internet
connection and also there restrictions
on what you can and cannot fit and we
were often stopped from filming in
certain areas by the security forces
just very quickly in Amisha what did
people there tell you about how they see
India's decision to remove this special
status that's when we people on the
ground are definitely angry they're also
scared to be speaking to the media
because their fury repercussions but
they feel like they should have been
involved in this decision and they
resent the fact that this decision was
taken unilaterally they're also
frustrated by the communication shut
down and want more autonomy they want to
be heard by the Indian government and
they want actually for the special
status to be reinstated but this of
course would be a longshot twz Magius
was speaking to us from Delhi thank you
for your reporting